[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nouvelle édition du sky
échos le magazine qui vous racontent la
vie des acteurs économiques du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes au strict uble incubateur de
start up du territoire depuis quatre ans
cette infrastructure accompagne les
entreprises et elle est en perpétuelle
évolution avec des nouveautés cette
année nous en parlerons avec son
directeur
c'est parti pour le quatrième numéro du
sky et qu elle conçoit des bijoux avec
des diamants de synthèse cécile da rocha
dirige la société jeannard aux paris
découverte de cette start-up
saint-quentinoise l'incubateur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines poursuit son
développement il intègre de nouveaux
services d'accompagnement des start up
les précisions avec son directeur jean
luc moreau alors que le sky business des
soutiens à 100% numérique le 26 novembre
de focus sur le partenariat entre le
grossiste alimentaire métro et le
glacier alter l2 entreprise basée à
trappes
avec l'évolution des conditions
sanitaires le gouvernement a pris de
nouvelles mesures pour limiter la
propagation de lakovic 19 en france en
contrepartie les entreprises vont
bénéficier des aides de manières
renforcé et prolongé
on fait le point dans cette séquence
décryptage
[Musique]
c'est fait
ce qui cube c'est avant tout un
accélérateur de croissance
un accélérateur de contact des changes
et en même temps on les aide à monter
l'offre de type a à répondre tout savoir
créer une entreprise quel statut
juridique
où trouver les moyens financiers
[Musique]
c'était le 8 décembre 2016
d'inauguration du ski cube le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines se doter
d'un incubateur depuis quatre ans
l'accompagnement des entreprises ne
cessent d'évoluer ici sur ce site et
pour en parler nous sommes avec jean luc
berho bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
directeur du ski cube quelles sont les
nouveautés ici au niveau de
l'accompagnement des start-up depuis la
rentrée 2020 alors je parlerai de
nouveautés dans le contexte actuel avec
le co vide qui effectivement nous a
obligés contraint à revoir un peu notre
stratégie et à prioriser d un certain
nombre d'actions le contexte n'étant
évidemment fin pas favorable à la
création et développement des
entreprises aujourd'hui nous avons ciblé
nos actions plutôt dans l'accompagnement
ou la prévention des difficultés à
l'accompagnement des entreprises qui
elles peuvent rentrer dans des
situations complexes et quel bilan vous
faites déjà depuis le déconfinement sur
ce test est là alors on a senti à
l'issue du déconfinement une reprise
notamment sur la création d'entreprise
avec des chiffres plutôt encourageants
malheureusement depuis une ou deux
semaines on voit un ralentissement
s'amorcer ce qui peut être source
d'inquiétude pour nous il ya aussi la
french tech paris saclay qui se
développe et qui dans laquelle vous êtes
intégré maintenant bien sûr ça ça fait
partie des bonnes nouvelles de cette
période de cette période puisque notre
incubateur a été reconnue et valorisée
dans le cadre du dispositif
effectivement que vous mentionniez donc
c'est un élément important pour nous
d'abord parce que effectivement ça mon
truc le travail qu'on a pu mener durant
ces dernières années est connue et
reconnue aujourd'hui
et puis ça veut dire aussi que ce
dispositif va nous permettre de
d'élargir un peu notre recherche de
start up et puis faire intégrer dans
notre incubateur de start up qui
n'auraient peut-être pas eu cette
occasion là si nous n'avions pas été
labellisés alors justement c'est
l'actualité c'est le 2 novembre que vous
lancer l'appel à candidatures pour la
prochaine promotion de start up qui
veulent intégrer le ski tubes vous
attendez quoi par rapport à cet enfant
alors pour nous c'est une phase
importante parce que
ce que nous appelons la phase 2 de
l'incubateur de 50 en yvelines
nous avons souhaité dans cette période
modifier un peu élargir un peu notre
notre panel de services proposés et nous
étions jusqu'à présent plutôt dans un
accompagnement généraliste avec un
prestataire unique et donc nous avons
choisi pour les trois années qui
viennent de prendre appui également sur
des experts du prestataire experts donc
le champ de compétences qu'on va
proposer dans notre incubateur être va
être beaucoup plus large et on espère
que nous permettra évidemment de
d'accompagner des entreprises sur
d'autres modalités aussi puis un sujet
extrêmement important
on parle d'incubation c'était vrai
compagnon les startups en amont du du
projet mais nous avons décidé aussi de
lancer une ce que nous appelons nous
dans notre jargon un dispositif
d'accélération avec un prestataire le
prestataire historique du plateau de
saclay pour accompagner les entreprises
qui ont déjà amorcé du chiffre
d'affaires mais pour justement les
accompagner pour les plus loin plus vite
dans le développement de leurs activités
donc on est sur deux types
d'accompagnement des entreprises très en
amont leurs projets mais également les
entreprises qui elles ont déjà commencé
à créer et développer de leurs activités
merci jean luc berho je vous en prie
directeur du ski tube l'incubateur du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une start-up incubés ici à saint
quentin en yvelines jana rose est
spécialisée dans la fabrication et la
vente de bijoux écologiquement et
socialement responsable son secret elle
se fournit auprès de laboratoires qui
fabriquent des diamants de synthèse
rencontre avec cécile da rocha
dirigeante de jana rose dans la vie
d'entrepreneur
[Musique]
je m'appelle cécile da rocha
cofondatrice de jeanne arrose paris une
marque de joaillerie joyeusement
responsable notre siège est à
montigny-le-bretonneux donc dans les
yvelines nous
nous avons lancé
ce projet depuis bientôt un an
[Musique]
mon activité consiste à créer des bijoux
uniques intemporel éthique et durable
l'engagement c'est que nos produits
respectent l'environnement et les hommes
par exemple nous travaillons des
diamants et lui en laboratoire
exclusivement il possède exactement les
mêmes propriétés physiques chimiques et
optique qu'un diamant domine notre
partenaire diam concept
fondée par alix dit qu'elle se situe en
france dans les yvelines plus
précisément aux loges en josas
et qui donc nos fournit principalement
en diamants de couleurs c'est des
couleurs qui correspond à la marque donc
cédé couleur cognac champagne
travaillons en slow conception c'est à
dire qu'on ne produit que les juste
quantité puisque on fonctionne avec un
système de précommande pour justement
déterminé c'est juste quantité et ne
produire que le strict nécessaire
[Musique]
en ce moment on lance une campagne de
crowdfunding pour en fait que notre
première collection joy voit le jour
valider nos matières valider nos
produits valider notre concept elle va
nous permettre également de développer
de la r&d pourquoi pas de créer avec nos
partenaires de diamants une couleur jana
rose
[Musique]
à noter dans vos agendas le sky business
des se tiendra le jeudi 26 novembre sous
un format 100 % numérique
pour rappel c'est le rendez vous des
affaires de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'année dernière 700 entreprises avaient
participé à deux mille heures rendez
vous au vélodrome nationale pour vous
inscrire rendez vous sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et dans le
sky échos nous vous parlons des
partenariats noués entre les entreprises
du territoire
exemple avec alter elle est le magasin
métro le glacier est devenue locataire
du grossiste de l'alimentation c'est
parti pour la séquence business sky
entre le glacier alpes airelles et le
magasin métro fabrique des glaces et des
sorbets durant la saison estivale
et puis là on va commencer à fabriquer
des desserts glacés pour pour les fêtes
metro france est un grossiste 'b to b'
qui a pour client à 400 mille
professionnels indépendants français de
la restauration et des métiers de bouche
[Musique]
à le père elle s'étend glaciers local
des yvelines avec lequel on a travaillé
qui d'abord à était client chez nous
puisqu'il s'est fourni en matières
premières chez nous avant de devenir
ensuite fournisseurs on a connu en août
2019 un incendie qui a détruit
l'ensemble de notre ancien laboratoire
de production notre ancienne fabrique de
glace quand on a vu ça dans le journal
le parisien on l'a tout simplement
proposé à elle perd elle de les loger
dans un bâtiment qu'on a à côté
quel ancien bâtiment des produits
d'équipement le magasin métro et notre
bailleur puisque c'est eux qui nous qui
nous loue le bâtiment dans lequel on
fabrique tous les journaux glace cette
aide a été elle s'est faite
naturellement en fait tout simplement
parce que ben voilà on commercialisent
leurs produits fournissent aussi chez
nous donc c'est tout naturellement qu'on
s'est rapproché d'eux pour leur proposer
une solution
[Musique]
c'est que que métro et un vrai
partenaire pour pour les restaurateurs
est donc c'est vraiment un billet un
biais qu'on veut utiliser pour se faire
connaître et pour augmenter notre
chiffre d'affaires auprès des
restaurateurs de la région
les restaurateurs alors un petit peu
moins cette année due à la crise du coc
ville mais représente à peu près 20% de
notre chiffre d'affaires le reste est
fait en grande distribution et l'intérêt
pour le magasin métro dans cette
collaboration il est double puisque ça
permet aussi aux collaborateurs de
s'immerger de voir le fonctionnement
d'un fournisseur local notamment glacier
de rencontrer aussi d'autres partenaires
locaux
[Musique]
on a pour ambition pour le coup avec
métro d'aller prospecter de nouveaux
clients ensemble ou on pourrait imaginer
un partenariat ou métro
et nous propose aurions une offre glace
clé en main pour la saison d'été aux
restaurateurs
avec peut-être un frigo des petits pots
à déguster en un clic pour renforcer le
partenariat existant avec alter elle est
ce qu'on a ce qu'on a décidé de faire
avec pierre basset de mutualiser nos
forces c'est à dire que moi je possède
des clients sur sur la zone que je
connais bien c'est la force de métro on
connaît bien nos clients est lui par
contre comme il se fournit
essentiellement aux produits locaux dans
la zone mali décennies mutualiser nos
forces et de pouvoir référencer un
maximum de producteurs et de et de
fournisseurs locaux
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et mission à revoir en
replay sur le site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]